Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Dream Daddy.http://www.youtube.com/timedtext_cs_panel?tab=2&c=UC8agHEcgOJUcPHD9w_EmnEQ
Now, we just got done with our second date with Craig, but we got a lot more Daddy to get through.
'Well it's been a long day...'
I'm just ready to pack it in.'
'After a few bites of ice cream from the freezer, I turn off all the lights and walk down the hall to my room.'
'I wonder if Amanda's still awake . That kid needs some sleep.'
'As I pass her room, I can hear a faint sound,'
'But can't make sure- can't quite make out what it is. I get a closer look.'
'Is she... crying?'
'I knock gently on the door,
'Hey 'Manda?'
'The crying immediately stops.' 'Not right now.'
'Her voice sounds strained. she sniffles, I
need to make sure she's okay.
'I open the door.'
'In the dark, I can see Amanda's outline in the middle of her bed, knees hugged up against her body...'
'Is everything ok?'
'I don't want to talk about it.'
uuugh
I... I just need to know if something happened...
'Did something happen?'
'No! Nothing happened, go away.'
ooh..
I don't want to press it too hard, if she doesn't want to talk about it, then who am I to... really pester her? Alright...
Something didn't have to happen..
People don't have to start crying just because something happens. Something could be bothering them for a long time.
She was almost crying before, too.
We'll leave her alone, for now.
gently behind me she immediately starts
crying again wow I have no idea what has
her so upset she seemed totally normal I
feel awful just leaving her to cry but I
also get the feeling that if I tried to
do anything else it would have only made
Yeah, I get that feeling too.
You know, like-
I just- I can't press too hard if someone wants to be alone, like, I-
I can't force my way in, it'll only cause more harm.
awful things she could be dealing with
right now more than anything I just want
her to be happy and safe I have a hard
time falling asleep when I finally do
I'm still thinking about Amanda after a
long night a very little sleep I roll
out of bed and make myself a pot of
coffee Amanda should be up for school
soon maybe she'll be willing to talk
about whatever's bothering her
about ten minutes before she's supposed
to leave Amanda comes out of her room
and makes a beeline for the freezer
Morna manda morning she drops a frozen
waffle in the toaster and slams freezer
door she won't look at me
yikes so anything big going on at school
today no okay do you need a ride to
school no want some coffee
Amanda pulls the toaster lever up and
takes her still freezer-burned waffle
out before it's finished cooking I have
to go
Amanda picks up her bag and story's out
oh okay I haven't seen her act like this
in a long time it's usually short-lived
but it always hurts
hopefully this blows over and things are
back to normal soon I sit back at the
kitchen table and look at a picture of
Amanda and I hang it on the wall in it
I'm teaching her to ride a bike her face
is a mixture of excitement and pure
unbuilt rated fear
I remember how determined she was every
time she would fall off some scrape her
knees she would get back up and tried
again finally I had to stop her because
she was bleeding everywhere then she
started to cry because she didn't think
she needed bandages and wanted to keep
trying as I put the bike away she just
stood in the middle of the street and
screamed then I took her for ice cream
and it was like nothing even happened
after giving it a bit of thought I
decided that if I force her to talk
about it I'm only gonna make things
worse but I have an idea
I start rummaging around for ingredients
I hear a man to walk in the door instead
of heading for the kitchen like she
usually does she makes a beeline to a
room she's clearly trying to avoid me
hey pumpkin
what can you come here for a second
there's a moment of silence yeah I want
to say sorry about last night I'm just
worried about you kiddo I get scared
when I know something's wrong and I get
even more scared when I feel like I
can't do anything about it
dad I so just whatever it is and you
don't have to tell me if you don't want
to whatever it is just know that you
have a dad in your corner who wants you
to be happy honey you know I'm bad with
words so I was hoping I could speak a
language we both understand I pulled a
cake out of the refrigerator and place
it on the table
hopefully this frosting is set by now
Dada Dada took me a really long time
because I ran out of red frosting
Sorry you're sad, but I support you 100%!
Right..
this is beautiful it's strawberry mana
gives me a big old hug I grab some
plates and forks and service up some
delicious cake so it's really stupid
what is this whole thing I know I've
been really weird lately and this just I
don't even know how to explain it I feel
like I might have to make you a charm
I'm listening
do you want me to take notes oh I guess
I should start on the top oh you know
how Mr is going to the fancy art school
What's the difference between Emma R and Emma P?
Oh, No..
The one who puked in Dead, Goth, and Beyond? No, that's what YOU did! The best friend? The OTHER one?
I'm gonna go with.. I think Emma R came first.
The Best Friend?
YEAH!
you anyways ever since she got the
acceptance letter I've been feeling like
she's drifting away you know and she's
been spending a lot more time with grace
and Emma P just thought it was all in my
head for a while but then I found out
from Rosie M that both of the Emma's
Grace and Noah all went to a party in
McKenzie X on the same night they'd all
told me they were busy studying for the
I do need a chart-
IhaveacrushonNoah-Eugh.. I dunno...
That is a TOTAL mystery to me. I couldn't have pieced that together from ANY of the information I had previously.
worst
anyway so the only person I told about
the crush was Mr and she promised not to
help tell anybody I didn't confront them
about the party thing because they
didn't want to start drama so I just
keep quiet and keep going about my
business Amanda sighs then one day I
invite everybody have to get notches at
the ball and after not texting me back
for like two hours even though none of
them ever put their phones down for more
than 30 60 seconds they all say they're
busy like simultaneously so I tell them
never mind I'll just eat nachos at home
right but we were out of chips and I
really want to run nachos totally
understandable go go the ball anyway I
get the food court in who do I see deaf
of grace a poppy mor and don't
hanging out together and eat nachos
without me why'd it gets better I'm
standing by the escalators watching them
and I realized that Noah has his arm
around mr which is kind of weird right
but then they kiss no yes I know so I
stole them over there and I'm like by
grace drops a nacho on her shirt because
of course she does and mor just glares
at me grace grace nothing's coming up
The-
Boring one?
I'm gonna SAVE! I DON'T THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT! BORING?
Yes! I think that's a passing, acceptable answer.
but anyway nobody will say anything and
I'm just like you guys suck which I
realized is not the most eloquent thing
to say but I was very angry and really
embarrassing I just want to get out
there so I left without nachos my god
which only further contributed to this
shitty day and immediately drafted a
super long text to the group chat asking
him why I've been so weird they've been
so weird and I wrote another one mor
asking how long the Noah thing's been
Oh, my God..
Eugh, What did Emma R say?
you know what let let me just read it to
you
Amanda pulls out a phone reads word for
word and arduously long string of text
I cannot- I cannot believe that.. *starts laughing*
Amanda's social life and well-being but
man do I not understand what you talked
about is all beyond me and I'm trying my
hardest to be sebuah they were dating in
secret for like months so I told her
that she's been really terrible friend
she's like well if you think I'm so
terrible then just stop being my friend
and I was like okay and then she left me
on red and then wait let me on red
what's that
Oh like she saw my message and didn't
reply and I know because there are read
receipts I don't know what read receipts
are but I'm just gonna nun pretend like
I know what I understand gotcha so while
this is all happening I talked to him a
peod about how mad I am because she's a
weak being kind of reasonable and
Abednego who are about pissed I and all
but ever I now know where Noah texts me
is like how could you say that about me
and I'm like say what about
he tells me the demo piece set
screenshots of everything I told her to
the group chat that I got kicked out of
alright I think you lost me on
screenshots but that definitely sound
bad so much more our blood honestly it's
all just really stupid teenager stuff
the bottom line is that everybody
dropped me at my great hates me and now
I have no friends Amanda so Cherie I
almost expected it from everybody else
but ours been there since dad died I
can't believe she would just stab me in
the back like that I'm not even that mad
that you dating no I'm just upset that
she lied to me about it for so long
Amanda stabs at the remnants of her cake
okay I get back I'm kind of mad she's
dating Noah like what did I do wrong
why did everybody just decide I'm not
cool anymore why wasn't I enough I don't
understand and as mad as I am at
everybody like I miss them dad Amanda
looks so dejected I almost can't take it
what could I possibly say uh-huh anyway
that's it that's old sordid tale thanks
for listening tune in next week for more
It's not dumb at all!  You got alienated like, by your group of friends! For, like, no reason!
Just because people can't talk about their feelings..
It's not dumb.
NO IT'S NOT!
guess unless you've secretly been a
robot who's been approximating human
feelings this whole time dad if I was a
robot it would have transformed into a
monster truck a long long time ago
seriously I know you probably don't want
advice but I feel like my duty as a dad
if it's still upon you a few nuggets of
HERE IT COMES! I'm ready! Let's see..
High school sucks-*breaks into laughter*
Yeah, it's pretty much the bottom line of everything. High school just sucks. It. Just plain-old does. But it's not forever.
High school sucks.
But once you're out of that, you get to choose who's in your life!
You get to choose who you surround yourself with!
get out into the real world you're going
to be exposed to all sorts of people and
it's going to be easier to make friends
with people who really get
some of those friendships can last a
lifetime I mean look at me and Craig
some of them only last a little while
and that's okay you're gonna make so
many awesome new friends at the art
school ultimately I think this says more
about their character than it does about
yours because you're amazing and if they
can't see that well that's their problem
I'll keep that in mind I look down at
the table did we just eat the whole cake
yeah we did you see the whole cake well
I gotta go run this off.
she closes the door she turns around hey
pops yes thank you you're always welcome
Awwww!
De-Haha-aww!
*giggles*
Awww!
That sucks though. Oh, they got high school relationship drama.
Oh..
It's always the worst. People drop people out of friend groups at the drop of a hat. And they don't think about the repurcussions of that.
And also people don't talk about their goddamn feelings! Oh, why's everything got to be lies and subterfuge?
Man, teenagers are the most-
Incredible liars in the entire world! Okay, all right. Hey Craig. Oh Craig Imma say, but hey Craig. How you doing Craig?
Man, if I got oh-You know what they say about third dates. Things get pretty serious. Are you sure this is Dream Daddy? Oh..
*laughing* Oh, God! I can't commit! I'm afraid of commitment!
What would I-God, I would have to date every single dad, wouldn't I? Wouldn't I have to date every single dad? Oh boy..
Oh god..
But I haven't..
Eughhh..
Agghh!
Do I go for the completionist route?
But I kind of want to see what it leads to right now-
Then I'll have a more educated guess on what's coming in the future. At least finish off this one path,
and then I can always go back to the save I just saved. Right?
Probably.
Maybe. I doubt that's 100% true, but I'm just gonna go with it.
it took some time for our schedules to
line up but I was finally able to find a
weekend where Craig and I could go
camping he always stays so busy with
working the kids but it's good to know
that we'll be able to spend some time
relaxing together in nature since our
first run of man's
regular runs with Greg I mostly do them
because it only seems like the only time
we did to hang out but the added benefit
is that I've seen a lot of improvement
Oh hell yeah.
camping gear from college Greg put me in
charge of bringing the sleeping bags in
the tent while he takes care of the food
so I got to check to make sure
everything is ready to go Craig should
be here any minute now a man is going to
be spending this weekend on a school
trip to our nation's capital
she hasn't been away from home without
me for longer than the day since she was
14 cheese and feelings nervous about it
as I am
I doubt it. She's probably excited!
sitting on top of her luggage in order
to get it finally yeah hey Bob's
ready for your trip once I get this bad
boy all zipped up I'm good to go
how much did you pack that seems like a
lot for two days oh it's all my camera
equipment lenses tripod flash you gonna
even have time to take pictures I'll
find a way I need to get some good shots
from a series of national monuments who
look serious about one of those internet
series where I reimagined Disney
Princesses our founding fathers I'm
kidding nobody likes those I'm taking
portraits of my friends oh I'm gonna be
in the woods out there in nature you
know roughing it just me and cracking
mother nature the old Mod the red dead
freeze are you gonna be all ready really
mm-hmm I'm gonna have any signal out
I know it will be a NIGHTMARE not to hear from me!
couple days without constant updates on
who just got voted off the International
haunted house hunters well I guess you
enter the record push down a flight of
They were really beautiful stairs.
suitcase and lifts into the next door
the four bedroom comes run give you a
big hug relax the head Ron I'm a big kid
now I can take care of myself
hopparoo know that there are robotic
standards and to mom chaperones the most
trouble I could possibly get into is
falling asleep at a tether ice cream on
me oh well all right don't feel anything
okay since you asked nicely
But I was gonna steal the Declaration of Independance..
my bag by me Craig's already strapped
some camping gear on top of my modest
foot status car he notices me carrying
my equipment and hurries over to take it
I say-now don't you...
Don't you fuckin' dare..
DON'T YOU DARE!
Don't you dare!
it's your weekend to relax take it easy
I guess I can't argue with that
everything's good with Amanda yep on our
way to a school trip to Washington DC
what about your offspring already in
Spanish Lee's for the weekend I'm ready
to get my camp on hello the rest of my
stuff into Craig scar and we get in Oh
No what's wrong I think I left my juicer
plug in we can't go back are you worried
that somebody's gonna break into your
house and cold-press some carrots no
it's just by to try to relax man let the
juicer float away take all your fries
and blend them into pulpy good vibes
Craig takes a deep breath do we have
anything to listen to uh all I have is
my place is a series of CDs that guide
OH YEAH! Shawnty's the best!
yeah Greg and me a thick case filled
with CDs take your pig thumb through
page after page of kids sing-along CDs
oh yeah twinkle twinkle little star
takes me back way way back keep going
because at the end of Jason find in the
very last slot of blank CD with Craig's
handwriting on it DJ keg stands mix
Volume one that made it just for the
trip I think you'll like it about the CD
into the car stereo and it's immediately
I'm transported to our old dorm room hit
after hit plays it's una for both
happily screams singing the lyrics to
each song as we fly down the highway the
song was Carl's favorite Carl the third
roommate brought the dog home one night
and I couldn't pry you two apart we
spend an entire semester fabricating a
story about a foreign exchange student
roommate who had a really bad confident
sound exactly like a dog's bark then we
had a room inspection that RA was so
suspicious of us but could never prove
anything
the girl was just under a blanket
blessed that pups courage under fire man
we did some dumb things back in college
the arse flybys we bailed out tunes and
whatever non-existent ear voices
register in soon enough we were
surrounded by lush trees and spectacular
vistas of everything amazing the needs
that's dope it feels good to be back out
here bro
real good we parked our car at the
entrance to a familiar trail load up our
gear on our penance
I'm thankful that I've been working on
the health over the past couple weeks
otherwise I've been dreading all the
hiking that's about to happen
Craig looks intently has his phone
everything all right yep we've got to
fire off one last working Craig pocket
saponin we start off on the trail
relatively easy but I know I would have
been huffing and puffing at this point
if you weren't all for all the murder
sprints I take a look around me and
taken all the tall trees and animal
chirps everything okay back there
there's no reception oh yeah being out
in the middle of nowhere will do that
Let's see..
The reception is the least of our worries! What about the BEARS? There are a lot of BEARS! (Imma save just in case)
Save dat here, okay. Let's see.
You trained for this.. Oh! That survival Wilderness training!
your calf muscles and fly out there like
a rocket ship all the way back to Maple
Bay you're going to be fine we're going
to be fine this is our weekend keep
marching down the trail but seems like
Craig is still worried after a vide
stopped in his tracks maybe we should go
back you can find another campground
that gets good phone cell reception
Craig seriously what's wrong I mean just
really nervous
my dad didn't think kicking into my mind
keeps conjuring up all sorts of
worst-case scenarios what if something
happens to the girls I don't have a
signal I have no way of knowing let me
tell you that feeling never goes away no
matter how old your kids are you just
got to remind yourself that they're in
good hands
Craig doesn't say I give them a
reassuring punch on the
trying to remember why we came out here
the plan was to get away from the goal
and just focus on ourselves for this
little trip no distractions no cell
service just to dad's relaxing out in
the woods Craig looks at me directly
beyond no distraction no cell phone
service to Dad's relaxing outdoors we're
going to have some fun this week
Greg and I get back to Mars not too long
of a hike before get to the campsite
we're both glad to see there will be
only people there can't believe you
still have extent bound into my attic
and already checked it for holes seen
better bit days sure but I think we'll
be able to spot I dump the bag of fabric
and bowls on the ground we unfold the
tent in the desired spot I am Craig the
sticks still know how to do this right
of course we do we do not up to 20
minutes to struggling like people in a
bad infomercial we somehow managed to
build an upright structure that closely
resembles what a tent would look like if
you ask somebody to draw a picture with
one roof - shut I wouldn't put this up
against the storm but I think we'll be
able to survive tonight we set out a
couple of chairs in our cooking
equipment admiring our handiwork bro
look at this go looking upon the kingdom
we have built upon this rock we shall
grill our me to drink our brews where we
hope the minion over this land verily
and look at our camping chairs which we
are going to sit upon so what's next on
our camp Stravaganza docket well now
that we have shelter settled I think
it's bambor as abusive exploring there's
a waterfall a little bit off the way
here we like let's get hiking man
recognize enter into the woods we amble
along taking our time to chat and Meyer
the wildlife
Greg reaches out and Armin stops dude I
Oh ma god! It does. It DOES LOOK LIKE THAT THING. THE THING THAT WE ALL KNOW IT LOOKS LIKE.
THE THING THAT WE REMEMBER THAT IT LOOKS LIKE FROM SO LONG AGO!
That tree looks like a butt- *Mark bursts into laughter*
perfect maybe even has a backspin
I thought we were going to have a great
time camping but this makes it even
better
Greg holds back up snicker I asked fire
to have everything get this one I'm
snickering to now let us analyze this
tree further Greg and I share our huge
belly laugh at our awful jokes the best
thing about this is that there's no
I think everybody out there is here to tell you your jokes are bad, almost as bad as mine!
I'll get there if I ever get to dad hood. We high-five. We're so cool!
Greg and I hit the trail again it's been
a long time since we've been out here
but everything seems more or less
familiar you point out old landmark said
we remember back from my college days I
think we're getting close down check it
out it's clearing up as we get closer I
can hear water running
GO SKINNY-DIPPING!
We're going to-we're gonna skinny dip!
beautiful waterfall spilling into a
large body of water that runs into a
river mouths a gape with the genuine
beauty of the place we go to investigate
the waterfall this bird gorgeous bro
nature so rad hearing further we get an
idea of how beautiful is I think we
could jump off of it like the old days
there's old dad here is happy on dry
land looks like you could climb right up
Oh, no! *wink, wink*
Whatever will we do..
taking his clothes off
*giggling* Don't look at Craig's butt!
Imma look at Craig's butt..
that that is one good but Kraig turns
around suddenly he catches me look off I
I do a lot of glute workouts, bro.
*Laughs* Major glutes in the running, you know. All the Murder sprints, ya know. I glute it up everyday. All day, everyday.
Major glutes.. and the running, you know- all the murder sprints, you know, they gluted up.
Every day, all day, every day.
And I ignore the fact that there were eggplants shooting out of his butt.
I mean- how high can you count?
Let's put on a show.. WHO NEEDS PANTS ANYWAYS?!
If ever there was a Markiplier way of addressing this..
Who needs pants anyways!
I AGREE!
Jump into love..
Aghh!
*Giggles his head off*
I've awakened the beast..
I'm a wild animal when I'm in  the corner! Let's see, hammer fist, dunk him, squirt water at him with your hands. Well. That's not very..
Dunk him? Hammer fist?
What a Hammer- Oh! is that like, Bloom? Oh, yeah, hammer fist. I'm not gonna dunk him!
Yeah..
I'll race you to the top..
I'm Gonna Race Craig to the top.
Aww, fuck. You know it. Oh god, you know it.
I- I live for danger..
Never felt more alive!
Alright, alright.
Okay.
It's getting cold.
Let's probably head back
Let me start the fire.
oh
*End of subtitles, rest is auto generated*
Go overboard
I'm going to go overboard. That's what I that's how I roll I over board really give him that by the present yes
You're an amazing hard-working father with a steady work ethic and everybody loves you
Your daughter thinks you're a superhero the neighborhood dad's respect. You immensely most of your blood looks great
Stop you make the cry
Okay, okay
Go on your tears putting out the fire
eventually Craig is
Miraculously able to get something going he blows on the embers and gently places the glowing moss into the base of the pit soon enough
We have a nice little fire going way to go man regular old outdoorsy fella Hooray for not dying, bro
Exceed ones lawn chairs Craig Broughton cozy up to the fire
Warming up my hands relax man. Take it easy. Let me handle dinner
My watch is Craig stokes the fire
And sets up a makeshift grill for the steaks if I just read this slower gets a lot more central
after all that hiking and swimming in
Fire-starting, I'm able to relax a bit with the sound of crickets in the scent of steak still in the air
I actually feel pretty calm Craig expertly sears two steaks in a pan
He's been heating up on the fire cracking time and crushed ginger over it while blasting them open butter
wow, I didn't know he was actually good at cooking the fanciest I ever saw him get in college was when he started sprinkling the
Seasoning packet onto dry ramen and eating it up straight
If this happened you cereal every morning with beer instead of milk. I grew up. I guess I
Think these are just about ready
Breakfast just stayed on steaks on a paper plate and sets them aside
I start to reach for one, but craig smacks my hand away dude. Let the rest that will be more flavorful that way
Patiently, I noticed that smooth jazz in the background I can hear that I
hear that I
Hear that I basically return to my seat eyeing the steaks longingly from a distance they smell incredible
Craig prepares a side salad for us in the meantime sprinkling feta cheese on the Roof freshly chopped greens
He played sit next to a generous pile of roasted potatoes covered in olive oil and Rosemary
Once it's all ready. We sit down by the fire and dig in
Everything tastes, okay, bro. Oh my God
I already know it tastes good. I'm salivating just fa5. That's what I like to hear
Remember how for an entire semester we would eat burritos for breakfast lunch and dinner?
It's so hard not to go back to that look at you now
Man your kids a great job great ass and now you cook like a vengeful wizard whose arch-nemesis in Microwavable food?
I'm really impressed by how much you've gotten your life together craig laughs, but there's no humor in it
Glad you think that bro glanced at Craig while he fixes its salad
He real grew out of his baby face
But something about his expression that makes him seem so much older than he is a sense of maturity he didn't have in college
He looks
exhausted
You okay? Oh, yeah?
Come on. I've known you for long enough to see when you're down. I don't know
I'm tired bro like being out here is making me realize just how drained I feel
You work really hard greg it can't be oh man. I have to for my girls. I volunteered their school
I cook them healthy meals for them. I do everything I can make sure they're safe and happy when they're with their mom
I'm always working overtime so I can support them
And you work out a lot so you can crush anyone who stands in their way?
I that and I don't want to fall my old habits
I need to set a good example for my girls everything. I do is for them, and I wouldn't have it any other way
But it seems like it's bleeding a try if that's what it takes to raise them well that it's worth it
Craig buddy. I know you're where you're coming from here, but you got to take care of yourself - I do though
I in exercising
It's not what I mean, man - little butter on too much toast you know do you get that I?
Could be more butter for you is what I'm saying your toast is so big. It needs my butter. You get me craig
You get me one you're spreading yourself, too thin lively it's balanced
It's great that you care this much about your kids, but can't neglect your own needs because you're too busy taking care of everybody else
You matter - I don't know it's just I know I can provide for my family
And if I take a step back and look at everything objectively I know I'm doing right by them
I don't know, but I can't explain it man
There's always that voice in the back of my head telling me
I need more to do more like it's never enough for me every time
I try to relax that voice keeps telling me. I don't deserve it to be honest. I feel even feel guilty being our goddamnit
I just realized I
didn't realize that dating craig cuz he's me ah
fuck ah
I have a great ass that I'm not enough butter for my big honking toast. God damn it. I'm cried
Craig you're trying your best, and you're doing an amazing job
That's a fact, but even if you weren't you would still deserve happy Mom man, do I though oh?
Yeah, bro. Oh, yeah, Bro, bro
elian
Hi, Abra
There are some significant difference between the two of these
In saves in case seems suspicious ah oh there
We go look at Craig and think about what a good friend and even better father. He's compassionate. He's hard-working. He's relentlessly positive
He encourages everyone to be the best version of themselves
He makes me want to be a better person if you could only see yourself the way I see you
Brick beams he gets up and walks over to his supplies. Come on. I brought the desert
Well, are you going to use the campfire to tour stops and some cranberries? Oh?
Oh what I know little nothing about cooking craig pulls out marshmallow
Hey, well, you still know how to make the s'mores right? I think the more important question is do I know how to make s'mores?
Do you know how to make s'mores as I recall uses is completely black in the marshmallows?
I stand by that it's charred on the outside
but gooey in centers preserved Brutish quick throws of marshmallows at me and I catch it in my mouth ah
remove
Used to be able to do that at a greater distance against the women disadvantage
Give me a week of practice and I'll be competitive again Greg
And I sit in the warm glow the campfire watching Embers float up towards the sky
The stars are so much brighter out of here. Yeah, I miss this mark
Me too. We stay here until it gets late half remembering stories from College
We watch as the fire dies and eventually clamber into the ten
Crawl into the ten nine for all Mice I?
unfurl my sleeping bag
Wait, where's the other sleeping bag?
Look around for a second. Oh, no, we only brought one
I musta left it at home
oops
It's all yours dude. I'm sorry. I'll just curl up over here in the cold
No way here craig unzips of sleeping bank and spreads it out
So there's enough room for both of us to lay on top of it
Hi, bro. Good night, bro. Roll over and we face away from each other without a blanket
It's really cold and shiver without realizing. I find myself nestling closer to Craig. I'm sure he won't mind
It turns over I feel its breath on my neck it's hard to focus on anything else
I turned over trying to get more comfortable
I opened my eyes to find Craig's faces only a few inches from my own for once he looks at peace
Sides flutter open his hand finds a place on my waist
Not sure who leans in first, but suddenly. We're kissing we look at each other again. My heart racing Craig. Oh, man
I got strong feelings for you bro feelings. I can't deny anymore
I run. My answer is here to the down his chest
Craig brings me closer wrapping his arms around me I feel so
broke
Secure nothing. I'm gonna make it run after that one rook here. I feel so bro
You know talking about old times fun good ah I like making new memories with you. God. It's cheesy
I don't care my smile tracing the lines of his hip with my finger. We kiss again not worried about it's getting too cold
I don't know what any of these scores mean, but I keep getting ranked s which I think is great
My total seems a lot higher than my points seem to suggest
Did it though nailed it got it?
Okay, alright. So anyway. I don't know if that's going to end in the game after that
But I'm gonna pause it here because obviously I want to play this more. God. I love it
I'll probably make longer episodes later on because it would take her ever if I just go deeper for Dad
So I'll probably just try to try to do longer episodes or more of it, but I had I love this game so much
It's just so good. Oh so good
so thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you think of this down the comments below let me know what the
The Craig path is and and obviously there are there are so many endings to this obviously you could have it have like bad dates
And whatnot and I know there's just so much exploring happening in the game
So let me know what you think and let me know what I should do next but I'm probably not gonna listen to this fall
To my heart that's what this games all about so, thank you everybody so much for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video
~Buh bye~ :3